jessica is in Boston hi Jessica welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show sure what's up
oh I'm in a very awful student loan mess
I racked up a three hundred eighty five
thousand dollars in student loans I know
are you a doctor or a lawyer I am a
doctor clinical psychologist okay after
seven years of graduate school that's
how much that I'm in and if I knew then
what I knew now what I know now I of
course would have gone after things a
little bit differently but my question
is though I just got a job in a
non-profit working at a school that
actually provides room and board and I
want to know how to tackle this that
with the public service loan forgiveness
program any ideas about that well it
sucks that's my idea you're saying the
neck you know I've already spent seven
years of my life on this education now
I'm going to spend another ten years of
my life with no life right with this
debt hanging over here for ten years
what here is your income so the income
starts off at 52,000 and shows that
every year you know make a lot more than
that in case you can't you make time job
as well no I mean can you not get as a
clinical psychologist and you not make
six figures
I couldn't profit practice so do it your
three hundred eighty five thousand
dollars in debt you don't have the
option of taking a cheap doubt job you
need to create some a good idea no it
sucks it means ten years and it's
falling apart the Department of
Education is saying that navient and
Sallie Mae don't have the
right to determine whether or not you
are qualified after they determined it
and they're bailing on some of these
people it's scared no way I want you to
do that I want you out of debt fast as
fast as you can possibly get out of it
so you get your life back
I mean this is oppressive is it not and
for that to just be hanging over your
head for the next decade that's the
student loan forgiveness program
it's a Cade old are you I'm 29
don't wait on 39 to start your life no
definitely not no I don't either and the
income that you give up working
something that qualifies for that versus
what you could make in private practice
during that decade would have paid this
all five times okay I'm gonna I hate to
say it but I want you to get I don't
want you to be altruistic I want you to
be it get all mercenary to the point
that you almost feel greedy because you
need to go make some money for your sake
kiddo once you get on this mess and you
need a bigger shovel this is not I mean
you may or may not follow my advice I
get it I understand you've got your
emotionally committed to this path but I
think it's a buying some you're giving
yourself a prescription of decade of
oppression that might not even turn out
I mean do a little reading on this on
what's happening with the Education
Department and how they're disallowing
some of these things and it's going into
court and there's been class-action
suits again it's just it's a mess and to
depend on the government for your
program to get you free instead of
depending on your ability to earn an
income isn't it's a bad idea I think so
I mean you can do what you want to kiddo
but you asked me my opinion if I were in
your shoes I would go make as much money
as I could make as fast as I can make it
legally and morally and get this mess
cleaned up and I would do it very very
intensely and very focused and very
quickly and you know I'm talking about
three four years you clean this up
but you'll have a life during that time
but then you get the rest of your life
with a life and and but you're gonna
have to you know really pick up you know
er on the weekends and everything else
you can do you know being on-call
anything you can do to add to a standard
private practice and so forth but you
don't have the luxury of working for
nothing if you want to unless you just
want to try to do this but I I know not
a chance
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]